here's a cnbc story this is why class
valedictorians
don't become millionaires everyone
remembers their class valedictorian
perfect grades perfect test scores and
in some cases perfect hair
they probably went on to professional
fame and enormous wealth right
not necessarily in his new book eric
barker explores the maxims we use to
discuss success he finds a valedictorian
rarely becomes standout successes
his assessments are based on research by
karen arnold a professor at boston
college and the authors of lives of
promise
what becomes of high school
valedictorian she tracked 81 high school
this is pretty interesting she tracks 81
high school valedictorians
uh after graduation she writes he writes
there are there was a little debate that
high school success predicted college
success nearly 90 percent are now in
professional careers
with 40 and highest tier jobs they are
reliable
consistent and well adjusted by all
measures the majority have good lives
but how many of them
are number one high school performers go
on to change the world the rule
run the world or impress the world the
answer seems to be clear you know what
the answer is
zero not one not five
zero it seems that the traits that set
one up for
exceptional success in high school and
college self-discipline
you know and the ability to comply with
rules are not the same traits that lead
individuals to start disruptive
companies or make
shocking breakthroughs valedictorians
aren't likely to be the future
visionaries
says arnold they typically settle into
the system instead of shaking things up
what are your thoughts
bingo you know i'll give the guy credit
for getting a lot of publicity for
writing a book
seriously you know i think i think i've
written a lot of books
i've written a lot of books tom's on one
day tequila tom is my favorite time
that's nothing hey i'm all for writing
books i've written 41 of them okay i
know what it takes i write
non-fiction he writes fiction to say
that there's zero valedictorians that
have been successful
this guy's a nerd that got shot down by
a valedictorian and he's probably a
virgin
i mean if you break through this okay
here's some names are these people not
successful
hillary clinton uh conan o'brien uh
cindy crawford kevin spacey jody
about time crawford was a valedictorian
yes
yes she was in dekalb illinois and you
can look all these up
verify them for me for him to say zero's
wrong but good job
in his study so he must have picked the
the certain people
look i think the key of what you
mentioned here that relates so much is
this this talk about norms and and not
having visionary breakthrough ideas
and that's what california needs uh
that was some solid spin he's leaning
into this whole politician thing
so hey he quoted at least you know he
quoted aristotle before i
i'll quote um marilyn monroe by saying
well
well-behaved women rarely make history
man and that's the that's the thing here
right like what makes you a
valedictorian it's it's obedience right
like you're smart but
high school's not hard college isn't
hard they tell you exactly what to do
and then all you got to do is do what
they tell you to do
there's no there's no innovation in in
modern education
there's a literal syllabus they say do
this by this day
because other people are trying to do it
as well sure fine
whatever yeah but i mean dude it's i
remember
uh watching i was there watching pat
with uh with jordan peterson he talked
about disagreement remember we talked
about the ability to be disagreeable
all right one of my favorite interviews
on this channel and he said he was
talking about like why
are men uh predominantly more in
positions of
power and authority than women and is it
because of societal systemic issues
and jordan peters said yeah some of it
but most of it is just because
they have a men have a predilection to
being disagreeable we don't mind
disagreeing with one another as you've
seen at this table today
whereas maybe it's the way women are
raised or maybe it's it's something to
do nature and nurture
but they tend to want to avoid that that
conflict at least
in in public not necessarily in private
but in public they don't want to be seen
as being disagreeable
and that ability to be disagreeable is
the number one determinant of
your ability to rise through the ranks
of business right so i
think that that there's something to be
said for the way and this goes back to
the earlier educat conversation about
education there's something to be said
for the way that we are systemically
teaching people
to be obedient not to be intelligent
and that's something that that we're
doing we are raising factory workers
we're raising people who need to show up
at a certain time
clock in clock out corporate clones
that's it we our public education system
is made so that people can effectively
work at amazon warehouses
not not create a competitor to amazon so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye